Urban Champion, are you tough enough to take on the baddest guys on the block?
And welcome to NEStalgia, the only podcast playing every NES game in chronological order.
I'm Mike. I'm Sam.
I'm Joe. And I'm Sean.
And guys, I just have a little disclaimer about our sign-off.
Mike, you have this wonderful sign-off in which you advise everybody to play it yourself if
you can. And I want to be clear that that is no way an endorsement to buy any game.
Because if you bought this game, I'm really sorry, and I don't want you to hold it against
us. I never thought of it like that, that I was telling people to spend their hard-earned
money on crap.
I said this in the episode where it's too late.
Yeah. It's too late.
Yeah. You know what? I'm so mad at them, but I'm going to listen to this episode just this way I can feel like
I got my money's worth.
Should we just get into the essential votes?
They're buying the experience.
Yeah. So we're talking about Urban Champion, a game that Nintendo decided to make.
It's loosely based off of their boxing Game & Watch game.
And I only say that because it's the same thing with the 2D, and you go back and forth
between two characters.
But it's different enough that, I guess it's different enough in the fact that this is 8-bit
and that was no bits.
That was just lights. That's what the Game & Watch is, if you think about it.
For those that aren't familiar, the Game & Watch is like a series of things Nintendo was
doing alongside their arcade games and stuff like that in the very early 80s.
And there's some cool stuff in there.
And I would never recommend buying a Game & Watch because they fetch high prices for what
is essentially a little toy that Tiger Electronics would later sell on kids' meals.
Because it has a collection of different shaped lights, right?
Yeah, exactly. That's what it is. You can see.
If you tilt it in the sun the right way, you can see every single sprite.
I played stuff like that when I was a kid.
But never a Game & Watch.
Yeah, it's an unfortunate thing of mine, too, that I've never owned or played a Game & Watch
and I'd really like to.
I've played some Disney creations that are very similar.
I played a Star Wars one, which is technically a Disney one now.
Look at that. Oh, okay. Yeah, that's very interesting.
Growing up as a kid, I did play the Game & Watch collection on Game Boy and I just had
no idea what that was.
It's just my mom got it for me because it's a Nintendo game made by Nintendo and had Mario
and stuff on it. And what they did was they took, besides Mr.
Game & Watch, they also had a version that
they Mario-fied everything.
So if it was like Manhole, this time it was like you could play the original Manhole or you
could play this version with like Yoshi in the middle and he would use his tongue to keep
the manholes up.
It was pretty cool.
I gotta say, Game & Watch collection is worth checking out, any of the versions really,
because they each have different games.
So volume one, two, three, or four.
Yeah, so some straight thoughts on the Game & Watch collection.
Honestly, I'm trying to talk about the Game & Watch collection more than Urban Champion.
So I think, you know, just real fast, Miyamoto is listed as a producer of this game, but I'm
not going to hold that against him.
You know? Like, you got, like, here's the thing about the artistic process.
You gotta just get everything out of there, because you can't just like hold on to an
idea. You gotta get everything out.
Right. He had so many good ideas into Mario Brothers, and then occasionally these weird ideas would
leak into the game, and someone's like, oh, save it for that other game you're doing.
And he's like, oh yeah, Urban Champion.
They really like this game.
What? They, like, Nintendo has a heart on for this game.
Love it. They just continue to re-release it.
There's even a, um, there's a 3DS version of it.
Are you serious? 3D Classics version.
No way. But here's the crazy thing about the 3D Classics version, okay?
Because they did that for a couple of, a couple, like a very rare amount of NES games got this
treatment, where they, like, made the games with 3D graphics, essentially.
It's a, it's a whole new sprite work and stuff like that.
Like, it actually, the 3D look is like they made the 8-bit pixel art into 3D.
They didn't just, like...
They just extruded it?
They actually, like, yeah, they make it look like Legos in a way, sort of.
And it's, like, it's really interesting that someone took the time to not change any of
the gameplay, but to change the art style.
I hope they were paid really well.
I think, uh, I think other than Miyamoto being the producer, though, everything remains
a mystery. So that's why I say I'm not gonna hold this against him, because for all I know, he was
just responsible for, like, the color palette.
You know? He was like, those colors look good.
I joke, but that's an actual job Miyamoto had during the NES launch days, is, like, for
every single game, he had to, like, one of his responsibilities was, like, picking out
the color palettes.
And, like, actually, it's pretty important.
Yeah, like, this is how these games should look.
Uh, I think we can just go straight to first impressions.
Joe? Cool.
Um, so, first thing I thought when I started playing this, is this is kind of like Nidhogg
without jumping.
Oh. It's very much, if you haven't played Nidhogg, I'll just describe what Urban Champion is,
because it's very similar.
But you, you square off against your opponent, which is, in my case, was the computer, um,
and you choose which height you want to attack.
Up or down.
And they either block up or down.
And blocking up is, like, your face, and blocking down is your stomach.
Right. And you can also dodge.
You could step back, yes.
Oh, stepping back. It's a dodge move, if you just press it once.
Yeah, but, like, okay.
No, I agree with you.
I agree with you. Yeah, I'm just saying, it doesn't change the manual dramatically.
Yeah, yeah. It's like, yeah.
Continue. Um, so you just try to knock through your opponent's defenses.
If you hit him in the face with his arm, with his hands down, he'll step back a little
bit. If you, if you hit him with a power move, he'll tumble back.
And you want to. He does, like, two sombersaults.
Yeah, he'll tumble way back.
And you just want to get him to his side of the screen.
You want to keep moving forward, making him move backwards.
You move on to the next screen, um, before he pushes you the other way.
So, the only.
It doesn't have.
The only difference is between it and Nidhogg.
It doesn't have any jumping.
And it's no fun at all.
Because Nidhogg is great.
Oh my gosh. But, uh, Urban Champion.
I, I was kind of excited when I saw it was going to be like Nidhogg.
And then it just, I don't know, it just didn't deliver.
Something about. Everything.
Yeah. Something about everything.
Something about it all.
Yeah. Okay, Sean.
Um, the one thing I'll say about it is, like, that the only thing that I like about this
game is, uh, like, the rough and tumble back alley, like, atmosphere they're kind of trying
to go towards of just, like, oh, we have to avoid the police.
Like, the police are something you shouldn't be around.
Like, uh, like, it's, it's kind of got a little bit of an edge.
But other than that, this is not a good game.
This is a sequence of press, of playing rock, paper, scissors, um, until one of you gets
to one side. Yeah.
Sam. This game is farts.
Nice. That's it.
That's your initial impression.
Oh, my, oh, and I guess that's not fair.
Are you sure someone did just fart in the room when we were playing it?
Yeah, was that your combined initial and essential vote?
Pretty much.
No, all right. So, initially, the game, it does look pretty good when you first put it on, you know?
It's got a nice little sky background, or it's got, like, a cityscape in the background.
And then there's, like, some music, I don't know.
Okay. Yeah. So, you're just talking about the complete audio-visual experience.
Yeah, but then once buttons get involved, go play.
That's a whole different thing.
All right. And I mean, like, so, yeah, there's some nice little touches in this game.
Like, you know, they're back and forth, and then a flower pot will drop, and if it hits
the right person on the head, they'll fall back.
They get stunned for a little bit.
Yeah, they get stunned.
And the police thing is honestly the only good thing in this game.
I hate the police thing. No, it's not good.
It's a good aesthetic touch.
No, but it's not just aesthetic.
It affects the gameplay.
No, I know. That's why I like it.
That's why I'm saying it's a good aesthetic touch, but what it does to the game is it
basically just says, like, all right, just start over now.
Yeah. Yeah, it resets you.
Yeah, so many times I'd punched the other guy right to the end of the block, right?
And then the cop comes, and my guy's like, oh, I wasn't doing anything.
And he stays at the end of his block, and I go all the way back to the end of my block,
and then I got to meet in the middle again.
Meet in the middle. Is there any rhyme or reason to win that cop?
I feel like it's... No, no, no. The cop just comes when he wants, but interestingly...
Because I only got him once. Yeah, so interestingly enough, I know none of us experience this, okay?
If the timer is up...
No, this happened to me. Oh, okay, very cool.
Yeah. Do you want to talk about it?
I feel like someone who's actually experienced it should talk about it, because it's very
unique. So, you know, there I was at the end of the alley, about to punch the
guy into the manhole.
In a 99-second brawl.
Yeah. And the cops come, and usually when they come, you run to each side, but when it comes, when
the time runs out, you can still fight a little bit more, and he just pulled me away in the
cop car. Yeah, you get arrested.
You or both of you?
No, you get arrested, and then it pushes back against you one level, you know?
So then you just kind of like...
Do you get out of the cop car?
Yeah, I think... Well, you don't get out of the cop car, you just kind of like appear, I think.
Yeah, it's like you're just taking you back a level.
Yeah. And I'm not sure if this is like...
I read this in a manual, but it was a while ago, I can't really remember.
He takes away the person who has like the lower stamina, or something like that, or he
takes away the person who's doing the worst, or the best.
It's probably the only time that these time limits and these stamina even matter.
Yeah. So, canonically...
99 second long fights and 200 stamina points, it's like, just get rid of that stuff.
It's tedious. It's unnecessary.
Did anyone, like, run out of stamina?
No. I never ran out of stamina.
You gotta do like a two-player, where one of us just gets hit in the face over and over.
I don't wanna play this game anymore. See what happens.
Joe and I talked about two-player, and it's essentially just butted mashing to the extreme.
I didn't play two-player, but I just assumed that's what it would be.
Usually I'm all for two-player.
Two four-year-olds playing Street Fighter 2, you know, like, just getting lucky, and one
of them does a Hadouken, and it's like, oh, I meant to do that!
You know, it's like, whatever.
Because what I did notice about the single player is that if you see his guards down,
that's a good time to get, like, 30 punches to the face before he puts his guard back up.
Like, you can hit him in the spot that his guard is not a lot before he puts his guard up.
So it's like, if his guard's up, just hit him in the stomach a hundred times, and then
he'll be like, oh, I should put my guard down and block these punches to my stomach.
If we're talking strategy, I had two strategies going into this game.
We can talk strategy. Yeah, so, first strategy was, you know, immediately after reading the manual, and it's like, all
this stuff you can do, and you gotta watch which way you block, and there are two types
of punches. There's your strong punch with B, which takes a little bit more wind-up, but it knocks
him backwards, and there's your light punch with A, which just kind of makes him take a
little step back. So you really want the B punch to land.
And so the first time I was trying to incorporate all this stuff, you know, I was trying to imagine
which way this guy would be blocking, if he'd be blocking his stomach or his head, I was
mixing up mine, you know, trying some A, trying some B, trying all this stuff, and I got my
ass kicked. You know?
The second time, I just went up to him and pressed B as fast as I could, and I won.
Yeah. This game would really rock with, like, an NES advantage, where, like, the B and the A have
the turbo buttons as well, and you just hold down the B turbo button and rock it to him.
It's like, really, that's all it took.
I just waited until his guard was down, punched him in the face, and then repeated.
And I would get punched in the face sometimes, but so would he.
The A button isn't powerful enough to justify how similar it is in, like, the amount of time
it takes to punch. There is a slight time difference.
Very slight. It's not like in Punch Out, you know, which we'll get to, hopefully, if we ever stop playing
Urban Champion, you know, where, like, the different punches actually matter.
In this one, it is just a slight time difference.
I also just found...
It is enough, though, to leave yourself open.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no. Sure.
And I definitely did get rock sometimes trying to go for the B.
But when you hit B, he tumbles, like, two full body lengths back, and when you hit A,
he takes a tiny step back.
Yeah, we have a step. So I feel like the...
The risk is...
Yeah. It's worth the risk to hit B.
Yeah. I also just noticed that he was guarding his face a lot more than his stomach.
I don't even know if that's just, like, particular to my game, but over multiple playthroughs,
it just seemed to be that, like, the default was to protect their faces, so I would just
mostly hit them in the stomach until they were like, oh, I should probably guard that.
I would probably protect my face.
I cannot believe we're talking about, like, the strategy of this game at this length right
now. What do you think...
Here's the one thing that I thought was interesting about this game.
I think that I was going to say, like, the rounds mechanic, and that it isn't just, like,
a constant back and forth, but that the manholes show up just dependent on, like, how many
rounds you have left.
So there can come a time where it's like, even though you weren't pushed back all the
way to yours, you're both down to your final round, so now there's a manhole on both sides.
That definitely made me feel like there was a little bit more at stake there.
There's a gamified element to it, you know, that I liked it.
Yeah, it's a cute touch, too.
And I like that whole aspect that there's not, like, a health bar.
It's just, like, it's a different way of, you know, don't get to that end of the screen,
don't get to that end of the screen.
I just don't think it was pulled off very well.
It kind of made me think a little bit when I was reading it in the manual, not when I
was playing, of Super Smash Bros, in that it's a fighting game where the object is to
knock your opponent off of the, you know, the course that you're on, or off of the
platform. Leave it to Sam to find a connection to Smash Bros.
Yeah, but I could see that.
But yeah, one thing also is the backgrounds, you know?
I thought it was cool how the storefronts changed a little bit.
And when I say changed, I mean, like, changed color and the name change.
But this, and I was like, oh, okay, I wonder what happens if I keep knocking him back.
I'm gonna see more stores.
Nope, it just repeats.
There's, like, no art in this game.
There's no mechanics in this game.
There's one mode, and then there's a two-player version of it.
It's kind of like when you pointed out to me that Jimmy Neutron, The Adventures of Jimmy
Neutron Boy Genius, that show has, like, a lot of repeating buildings.
Yeah, repeating buildings.
You know, like, they just, like, if you really look at the backgrounds, nothing's happening.
And I'm like, oh, that's disappointing.
I really liked this show as a kid.
Here's a fun fact for everyone.
Go and look in The Adventures of Jimmy Neutron Boy Genius, the TV show, at what they eat for dinner.
Because it's always weird.
And it's always funny. Like, they'll just eat, like, a hundred pieces of baby corn or something.
Like, they'll just get one texture and just repeat it over and over and over and over.
And all the paintings in their house are the same painting.
I guess that makes sense for why they had that ice cream shop, too.
Like, it's so easy to just, like, do CG ice cream.
Like, it's just liquid.
There was one where it was just, like, a whole can of cranberry sauce.
The time that Nostalgia was taken over by Jimmy Neutron.
That's how good this game is.
We're talking about what Jimmy Neutron eats for dinner.
Oh, no, no, it's not the last one.
But for me. Okay.
For me. Sure.
And then Sean's going to leave and then we'll finish the episode.
There are several different kinds of mics on this show over several episodes.
There's the mic that'll take you on a...
He'll take your hand and he'll bring you on a little get it adventure, like, exploring this video game.
And then there's another one where he'll kind of let one of us that may have found more enjoyment in this game take the reins and express themselves.
And then there's Contemptuous Mike that is one of my favorites to interact with on this podcast.
Because it lets us talk about Jimmy Neutron for a good, like, five minutes.
Here's the thing, okay?
It's like when...
And this has happened now for the third time, if I think about it.
It was maybe the fourth, okay?
Gyromite's the first example.
Stack Up's a huge one.
Maybe Donkey Kong Jr.
Math. We got there.
And now we're getting here again with Urban Champion.
The problem is, with games like these, is that they make me lose faith.
In, like, these video games.
Like, the concept of what we're trying to do here.
Play all these games.
I knew that there were going to be bad ones.
I didn't expect them to be this early.
And I also didn't expect for kids to be shelling out $35 in 1986.
It's like $300.
It's like, yeah.
It's a little bit of an exaggeration.
It's like $450.
Okay. It's crazy that these games get by, and everybody talks about how good the games were on the NES.
And it's like, it's very easy to forget Urban Champion.
Nintendo doesn't want you to.
But it's very easy to forget it.
Why do they parade this game so much?
They love it. I've seen more ports of this than Mock Rider.
It's insane.
If I put myself, though, in the shoes of someone not recording these episodes, but just listening to them,
I think, I mean, I would love hearing the episodes like Mario Brothers and the great episodes.
But I think I would also love hearing the bad episodes.
Like, I don't want to play those games.
You get to hear about Jimmy Neutron also.
Hey, listener. Do you like what you're hearing right now?
Yeah. Why don't you write in at contact at NostalgiaCast.com with your thoughts, maybe a question, maybe
ask us something different than what James from Milwaukee asked us the other day, and we'll
answer that question.
So I have to kind of, like, close this out now.
But I just wanted to ask if any of you guys know what it takes to become the urban champion.
I played up until, like, round 18, and I don't think you can be crowned champion.
There's just going to be another punk on the next street corner.
Yeah. Okay. Violence just makes more violence.
I learned from this. I don't know.
I didn't even, it didn't even occur to me.
You didn't think you, you thought you were the urban champion.
No one told you.
It wasn't like, a brawl has broken out on 40, 15.
You are the urban champion.
I was just so programmed from my pride to just assume that.
Me of the title character. Me of the top is the urban champion.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, Sean, you were on, like, your 18th fight, right?
Yeah, 18, round 18, like, my fifth win or something.
You probably, oh, your fifth win.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's a big difference, okay?
So your fifth win, so, you know, around, like, 10 wins, you get, like, a 10, you get
title, 25 wins, you get another title.
You have three lives to do this.
Unfortunately, you were about 140 wins away.
Oh, my gosh. Seriously?
Does it get more difficult?
You must win 145 fights in a row.
Oh, my God. To be crowned the urban champion.
Does it change, or does it, because I feel like it's difficult for us playing now, but
I feel like once you got used to it, you could probably expand.
It doesn't get any harder in the sense that, like, once you get to level 100, they get
really smart. Nothing gets really, really boring.
Oh, my God. And, like, visually, nothing changes.
Visually, nothing changes.
Gameplay-wise. You just, you know, they just put something in there for the extra go-getter.
How did you make me, like, have less respect for this game?
145 fights, and you get the rank of champion.
And that's all the time we...
No, no, no, I'll tell you. We gotta do something about this.
So let's bring it in to the Essential Games list.
I like that you say we gotta do something about this.
We gotta stop urban champions.
We gotta bring this to the vet and get it euthanized.
I'm sorry. All right, it's time for the Essential Games list.
If you don't know what this is, basically, we're deciding if these old NES games are still
worth playing today.
Yay! That's because there's no reason to figure out if they were worth playing then.
We don't have a time machine to go back in time, and even if we did, we'd still have
the bias of 2018 on us.
So instead, we're just looking at them and how they are today.
Urban Champion, you know, it's a fighting game.
Before Street Fighter 2.
Yes, that's true.
Before Mighty Morphin Power Rangers, the fighting edition.
Before, way before Dragon Ball Fighters.
Or is that Fighter Z?
Fighters. I think it is Fighter Z.
I always say the Z is like a Z.
Z. You know, like Fighters.
So with that in mind, you might think that like, oh, you know, you gotta give it its due.
Right? It's an early fighting game.
It doesn't have Street Fighter 2.
No. We don't do that here.
That's not the point.
In fact, a game like Street Fighter 2 should be celebrated with that context because of
how much it innovated and changed the fighting game genre.
We applauded Super Mario Brothers for that with the platforming thing.
It like, it really, you know, in a way became like the Citizen Kane of video games because
it took so many different elements and made them good.
Urban Champion takes a whole lot of nothing and just continues to be a game about nothing.
So with that in mind, I am voting no.
Joe? Yeah, I honestly don't have too much more to say about it that we didn't already say.
I think you can skip it.
Play Nidhogg.
I love that recommendation.
Yeah. I wouldn't have thought of that.
I think Nidhogg is the way to do this concept right.
I kind of love when we do that with the Essential Games list, like where we mentioned, like,
you kind of did that with Mock Rider where you're like, hey, here's some other games.
Like, I think that's cool when we throw out games that are worth checking out as well.
Yeah. Very nice.
Nidhogg. Yeah.
I actually didn't even put that together while I was playing this game because I enjoyed Nidhogg.
And because I was having so little fun, I was just mindlessly playing this game.
I didn't make that connection.
But yeah, I think that there's a little bit of, like, there's a little bit of presentational polish on this game that it doesn't deserve.
So that's like my one pro and everything else is garbage.
It's not essential.
Well, we would hope we could expect some kind of polish from Nintendo.
Unfortunately, it just wasn't in the right area.
Exactly. I prefer if this game looked like Popeye but played well, it'd be fine, you know?
Not saying that Popeye isn't by any means essential.
Sam. All right.
Well, here's the thing.
When you look at this game from the contextual lens of someone from...
No, it's bad. It's a horrible, horrible game.
Stop while you can.
It's... This is in the jank folder.
It's, you know, it's just...
Ooh, a welcome addition to the jank folder.
This one's in the jank folder for sure.
It is not a good game.
There's no content in this game.
And the content that is there is bad.
It's not essential.
All right. There you go.
Four votes and it's pretty much not essential.
I don't think anybody would even say play it.
Pretty much. It's pretty much not essential.
I'm pretty sure nobody would even say play it.
So I think that's all the time we have for this episode of Nostalgia.
Join us next time for Tag Team Wrestling.
And be sure to play it yourself if you can.
Not saying that you should buy it, but if you're happy to have it around, check it out, maybe.
Also, we're selling NES games if you want to go on our website.
Yeah, go on our website. We're selling them at a friendly markup from your pals.
No, we're not selling anything.
But you should go to the website, NostalgiaCast.com.
N-E-S-T-A-L-G-I-A-Cast.com.
Because there we have stuff like, is NES Baseball Haunted?
And other cool stuff too, like some weird ROM hack games that are worth checking out.
We do reviews for each game.
And they're not really like reviews.
We don't rate them or anything.
We just kind of talk about them.
Similar to how we talk about them in the podcast.
Also have like cool show notes and stuff that take you to other sites.
Gasp. Other sites.
No, we'll let you go to other websites.
We're cool with that. Because you know why?
We like you just for listening to us.
And since you're listening to us, you might as well hit that subscribe button and continue to listen to us.
Smash that like button.
Yeah, we do new episodes every Friday.
They release at midnight.
And I don't even suggest listening to them at midnight.
You know, get a good night's sleep.
Get them in the morning. While you're at the gym or while you're eating breakfast.
Or Sean, what do you do in the morning?
A balanced breakfast.
Go to the gym. Eat a balanced breakfast.
You know, don't smoke. Don't drink.
Become the urban champion.
Just 140 victories away.
You know, and so again, as a listener, thank you so much for your support of Nostalgia.
We thank you for spending time with us.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on at Esposito Film on Twitter.
And I'll talk to you soon.
I think that went as bad as well as it could.
Yeah. Very cool.
It was a funny episode. I thought it was a great.
Jimmy Neutron grade stuff was great.
Is this the worst game we've played?
No. What's the worst game?
I think Staggup. Well, you haven't played a lot of the bad ones.
Well, I mean, those don't count.
Rob doesn't count. Rob doesn't count at all?
Yeah. I'm still saying Tucky Kong Jr.
Bad. Fair.
I don't know. Let's see.
I'm trying to think. Wait till you play Tag Team Wrestling next week to decide if that's the worst game you've
played because it's pretty damn bad.
This could be the worst for me.
If we can't count Rob.
I think Tennis is pretty bad also.
Whoa. I wouldn't say that was bad.
Tennis was tough. I wouldn't say it was worse than this.
No, you're right. You're right.
I was playing that earlier.
Chris, what do you think as a listener?
What do you think has been the worst game we've played?
He only played Arkham Asylum.
Arkham Knight. Oh yeah, this game, Urban Champion, we get zero out of five Arkham Knights.
Oh yeah, not Arkham Knight.
Not Arkham Knight. I mean, yeah.
Let me pull up one note.
All right, guys. Remember, ruined my morning though.
We're talking about Drakengard.
Drakengard? Wait, that's not the game we're playing.
Oh, it's not? Oh, Drakengard's the game where the child is the big villain at the end of the game and
also one of the guys is a pedophile and the other guy, each, the other woman who's hanging
out with the new girl and each children.
You're thinking about Drakengard.
Megan is the one that is the villain.
Yeah. And then Dan is the pedophile.
It's nighter. I kidded.
Wait, did you, were you the one who showed me the brick and, someone said brick and mortar
is like, oh no, no, you're thinking of brick and mortar and then someone else was like,
oh no, no, you're thinking, and it went on for like, it went on forever.
No, I did not send that to you.
What I do is none of your fucking business.
My favorite game. There's no more Rogers in the world.
You're right. Do you know anybody named Roger?
The only Roger I know is, that's his last name.
Okay. No, I know Roger. Okay, cool.